金のトランペットをやってる人は見えるじゃん、あれ。
うん。
それじゃなくて。
金の人たちがあるから。
ああ。
そうね、なんか、
あれはもう、時間でなんか、みんな、みんな座って、お祈りとか言って、みんなこうやってたんこうになって、あの、やる、やって、それで、
ね、はい、そう。
何してる、ミスラムとか言うの?
うん。
それって、あの、何人が多いと思う?
どういう人がそういう人なんだ?
え、わかんない。
だけど、あの、みんなとこはもう、日本人と同じでね、顔が、それで、あの、日本語もペラペラなのよ。
え、インドネシア?
そういう人、あの、ミスラムっていうスーパーがあってね、
そういう人と、すごい可愛い男の子でね。
うん。
そういう人とね、何故か話すようになっちゃって。
そしたら、あの、それで、ある時、あの、今日は彼らいないんですかって、私、それ聞いちゃったんだ。
そしたら、誰かが呼んでたんだ。
よく行ったんだけど、ただ聞いただけだったんだけど、呼んで、降りてきて、それで、そしたら、今、お祈りしてたんですよっていう、
ああ、うん。
そういう人と、えぇ、って、お祈りって、私も、お祈りの時間があるんだよって言ったのね。
それで、あの、クリスチャンなのって言ったら、うん、あの、ね、ブルークラブなんだって言ったの。
へぇ。
だけど、もう、見たとこ、本当に日本人に、それが、少し、ちょっと黒いかな。
まあ、ちょっとだけ黒いんだけど、でも、すごく可愛いんだけど、でも、なんか、
そこで、私も色々失敗したから、日々から、松倉に行かない。
えぇ。
だって、だって、あの、あの、あの、メールアドレスするみたいなの、あの、お電話で、かけられる。
うん。
電話かけて、なんか、ちょっとかけるじゃない。携帯に。そういう、そういう番号だって言ってくれたからね。だから、なんか、色々書いちゃったね。
あ、そっか。
そういう人は、それ、彼1人の方がなかったの。
あははは。
そういう、そんな人が見ちゃってね。
うん。
それなんか、あの、あの、書くのはダメだったんだよって言うわけだったんだけど、そんなことしたって、そうマルーンを流したら、電話なんか、普段できないですね。
そういう人がやっているのが、そういう人だからね。あの、あの、実はいなかったかな。
実はね、あの、実はね、実はなかったよね。なんか、みんなで日誌に行った時、いっぱいなかったよね。
彼がいたのかな。誰か、アムちゃんが、誰かいた。
彼が、アムちゃんが、誰かいた。アムちゃんが、何かいた。アムちゃんが、何かにアムちゃんがいたの。すごい綺麗だから、みんなが、アムに行った。
そう、彼と、誰かと私と、